I I really liked bikes plus it was
actually for like a DC bike conference
like about five years ago but now I am
senior data scientist and manager at
code Academy and today I'll be talking
about anomaly detection with time series
or my alternative title how to know when
thing is terribly wrong so a little bit
about me first I'm a proud New York are
I've been a member of the New York art
community since about 2015 or 2016
but I'm born and raised in Brooklyn and
so been there my whole life and I'm
currently at code Academy but before
this I was at JetBlue and New York or DC
sports clubs and here's just some social
media stuff if you want to tweet along I
know Emily will be okay so my abstract
it's kind of one thing and you can read
the full thing online but basically my
guarantee for this release conference is
that I will help you uncover blind spots
and large data sets and hopefully reduce
fire drills that work
hence the burning fire emojis so we have
a lot to cover today so today we're
going to go over time series data and
then we're going to learn how to plot
and visualize data on using Google
Trends data the tidy way and we're also
just going to explore different
algorithms for anomaly detection and
talk about case studies how this can be
used at work or for personal for fun
so this whole talk started cuz Sherrod
pitched an idea to me to do a talk on
forecasting but what Jarrod didn't know
is that I have a really complicated
relationship with forecasting and so why
is this so he knows that I've been
working with time series data for a
while but in doing so I realized that as
data scientists when we work with time
series data we want the data to be clean
and ideally if we want it to be rota
forecasted they're like clear seasonal
trends either daily weekly this is like
Google Trends data for Halloween so
annually we see an uptick this is like
for castable data or maybe something
like this where people look up movers
throughout the year around the same time
of a month and there are a bunch of
people who move in the summers they see
like annually a year over year you see
clear trends the thing that I realize is
that for a lot of companies or public
policy or just a lot of data sets that
we handle aren't forecast grade so
there's this clash right like we want to
work with data that it's for castable
that we can predict stuff with and model
off of but we often work with data
that's highly inconsistent terabytes in
size and instead of there being like
several key metrics for you to direct
your attention towards your boss is like
can you look at this and like these ten
other things so it becomes really
difficult to monitor and a lot of I feel
like my job is diagnosing things and
it's like finding a needle in the
haystack so I think for a data scientist
in like the tech industry growth is a
double-edged sword so you see a lot of
these hockey stick growth charts and
obviously working for any company you
want it to grow and do well but it makes
it really hard to do anything cool or
fun with the data because it's so
unpredictable and the volatility just
makes it really hard to do any modeling
so here's an example of some data that I
work with and you can see that hockey
stick growth right here and when I try
to project out to 2019 using this is a
forecasting package profit which is open
source my facebook look at when you boop
the degree of uncertainty for 2019 and
so I thought this forecast is like not
actionable or useful and it's just not
not really great so so I just want to
switch gears and talk about dealing with
fire drills at work so how many times so
a lot of the time I feel like my job is
like close so I joke around my product
manager that were like firefighters and
constantly putting out fires so these
are real emails and slack messages from
work you can see it's like April August
September like every month there's a new
fire drill and something is terribly
wrong and oftentimes by the time we
realize that it's kind of too late so I
think by the time we saw this I was
already down here and we would have
wanted to realize this like wait earlier
right and the reality is something like
this can result in like if you're
working for a business it's a lot of
like time and money that's going down
the drain if you're looking at like
natural disaster data or something like
you could have you could be missing like
some sort of earthquake or something
like that so I feel like it also the
problem of fire drills is it really did
pass through your workflow so I'm
working on something really fun exciting
like long-term analysis and then
suddenly like I hear my BP and it's like
drop everything like CodeRed start
working on this thing and then I just
you know lust after other thing that I
actually wanted to work on so I pitched
this idea to Jared to talk about anomaly
detection in time serious data which I
found really useful at various companies
I worked at an even more actionable than
any type of like weak for housing model
so yeah so anomaly detection leads to
earlier detection and hopefully reduces
the number of fire drills and I think a
lot of people get the feeling that a lot
of the time our work is more like
reactive and proactive so this kind of
helps us get ahead of the curve so here
are some applications of anomaly
detection if you remember my DC our
promise at the beginning of this talk
it's to help you uncover blind spots and
large data sets so an example of that
would be the chart I showed you before
that was breakage at the last company I
worked at in an airline like flights
have gone out empty because of a human
error and we would have been able to get
ahead of that with anomaly detection so
so this is going into you the end of the
talk where I will simulate live coding
but hopefully by the end of the talk
we'll be able to go from this to this
which plots your outliers and anomalies
really nicely and you can export and
like you can do like cool things like
send emails to your team when like
something drops so so let's get started
I put up my POC on dub and I'm going to
add the slides after the talk but one of
the really cool parts about going from a
fortune 500 like non tech company to a
tech company means I can like share my
code now which I haven't actually been
doing very much but this is like the
first big thing so hopefully it keeps me
accountable so the first thing we're
gonna do is create a data frame so I
showed you some proprietary data before
but I thought it would be cool and fun
to use like Google Trends data so here I
pulled the Google Trends data for the
word vote for 20 or for 2004 to 2018
and produce the table here to see that
everything worked okay and then that's
the two packages that we use art ID
verse and anomalies so anomalies
actually sits within their tidy verse
and it was just released this year in
April so it's really new it like draws
from anomaly detection which is open
source by Twitter but it plays really
nicely with a tidy verse and it's Matt
dancing I think at business science does
a lot of cool packaged work so this is
all things to his package so first we
prepare the data and get it ready for an
all moist and then this is all the code
that you have to run which looks kind of
lengthy but I promise it's not that bad
and you can mostly like plug in place
off afterwards for fun and you come up
with this so for the word vote you see
some like cool trends here like these
are the presidential elections and oh
for obama obama reelection that giant
uptick of there is a 2016 election and
the really cool part is the midterm
elections actually outperformed the
glass view presidential elections
because of all the momentum so that was
really cool to see and then so i'll talk
more about the methods used up there
twitter and g ESD but i wanted to
replicate this with florida to see if
this was like a proxy metric so it's
kind of cool you see the seasonal data
here so around the beginning of every
year in the winter all the DC in New
York like snowbirds jump down to Florida
because we're too weak for the winter
and then and knows that those aren't
outliers but these over here this is the
2016 election and I believe this is the
midterms and I'm not sure what these are
maybe like hurricanes but
yeah you can see how like Florida being
the swing state correlates with election
timing yeah so I'm not going to go to
the slide too much but anomalies also
has features where you can like look at
the inner workings of how the algorithm
detects the anomalies so there's just
like a lot of really cool functionality
you can use so I'm gonna go over briefly
like what method you should use so I
think this is like my cheat sheet for
anomalous so Twitter and GSD does really
well for highly seasonal data so the
voting data that I showed before there
are a lot of like annual trends or for
your chance to year trends in voting
data but for everything else
standard Louis and IQR tend to do okay
and trend period I think that's like the
fun part where uses apply your domain
knowledge so if you know a lot about
like loading or like if you want to
analyze like your favorite sports player
or something like that you can do all of
that so going back to you when plus I
used earlier the moving data here you
can see the difference between so this
is a default so standard Louis and IQR
you can see how like it doesn't really
detect the trends and moving data from
2005 to today and it points out some
outliers but when we use the Twitter
method it controls our seasonality so
you see these like clean trends and
remove the outliers and then once you
pull in GSC which is also from Twitter's
anomaly detection package you can see
how the gray area Titans select a stream
Valley
oh you can try this on different
keywords I mentioned like sports or like
pop culture so I thought something that
would be funny if we're not looking at
longer term data would be Pete Davidson
um so so this is so for those of you who
don't know
Pete Davidson is a comedian on SNL who
kind of went viral and like broke the
internet this year with by getting
engaged to ariana grande who's a pop
singer so they met around this time I
mean got engaged shortly after so
internet went crazy you instantly shot
up in Fame and since this is 2018 data
we can use STL instead of with the
Twitter method and then the second
outlier was a few weeks ago when they
sadly broke off their engagement yeah so
you can do a lot of cool stuff I would
recommend playing around with it try
this out you can use whatever data you
like you can replicate this if you want
you can do you can look up your favorite
politicians yeah it's it's a really cool
package and I think a good addition to
the tidy verse I'm trying to see
[Music]
yeah so there's a lot more this package
can do you can see the documentation I'm
looking to hear and I'll have the PDF
slides who might get hub but yeah
there's a lot more I can do than it I
didn't get to go over today but
hopefully just just pick it up and go
Google Trends is also really fun data
don't work with so the last thing I'll
leave you with it's just good luck and
have fun the New York our community I
think has like been a real like gem in
my life of just like professionally and
personally like the bike rides and pizza
which Jared will hopefully pull up a
picture of later and yeah like I've just
met some of like smartest and funniest
and like interesting people with like
weird niche knowledge about things so
that's always fun so yeah if you're new
to it don't give up have fun with it
like analyze weird things do whatever
you want but yeah have fun with it
[Applause]